i actually believe that we are now 100  guaranteed to get a new redesigned mac  mini at apple's event next month john  prosser's original renders created by  ian's elbow showed off a much thinner  mac mini with rounded off edges at the  top and a plexiglass top looks like  we'll be getting four thunderbolt 4  ports however some of this doesn't  really make much sense so apple insider  decided to make their own render of the  new redesigned mac mini and i think the  thunderbolt spacing makes much more  sense here now i do expect this model to  come with the option of a 10 gigabit  ethernet port and it looks like it's  getting the new magnetic power connector  and you'll see that there is a perfect  opportunity for apple to add a thin  crack all around the edge of the  plexiglass top and that can act as the  intake for optimal cooling of the chips  i don't expect it to get anything more  than the current m1 pro and m1 max chips  and i personally expected to come in at  12.99